Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight, founder of
a category‐defining company,
Spanx,
Sara Blakely, joins the Tank.
These two Shark women are gonna
take a huge bite out of you.
Join me as we show
the world
the beauty of Africa
in design.
So, who wants to blow this
market out of the water?
I like a lot of it,
but not enough of it.
‐As a mom, it's a hit.
‐As a dad, it's a hit.
As a future teller,
it sucks.
I have to call out
the white elephant
for me in the room.
Radzely: I just need that person
that has been there,
done that,
knows how to make money.
We're ready to scale.
I think that it's super‐cool.
Oh, I can't get it off,
for real!
[ Loud pop ]
‐Oh!
Oh, my God!
And that is how you do a deal.
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is what
the entrepreneurs believe
is a more elegant way to gift.
♪♪
Hi! I'm Sal.
I'm Alex.
And I'm David.
We're the owners
of Bouquet Bar.
We're seeking 10 ‐‐
We're seeking $150,000
for 10% of our company.
Thank you very much.
[ Laughter ]
It's not always easy
buying a gift for someone.
Take a moment.
Think about the last time
you had to order a gift
for a family member,
friend,
or a co‐worker.
Were you happy
with that purchase,
or did you just wind up
buying one of these gift cards
'cause you couldn't find
what you were looking for?
‐Yes.
‐[ Chuckles ]
Well, we have a perfect
solution for that.
Welcome to Bouquet Bar,
an online gifting platform
that has taken flowers,
unique gifts,
combined it
with amazing packaging
for a whole new elegant way
of gifting.
Here's how it works ‐‐ Choose
one of our designer gift boxes,
then add the gift
of your choice.
Whether it's lavender‐infused
dark chocolates,
organic tea blends,
or beautifully arranged flowers,
the possibilities are
endless with Bouquet Bar.
Add a custom note, finishing
touches to your gift box,
and send it to that
special someone.
So, Sharks, who wants
to help us...
All: Bring the art of gifting
to everyone?!
Okay, we're past that, guys.
Let's do some amazing treats.
‐Okay.
‐All right.
We like treats.
Don't we, Kevin?
A moment on the lips,
a lifetime on the hips, Lori.
You know what?
He always says that.
Only to a girl.
‐I'm just saying...
‐Wow!
‐What is this?
It smells so good.
Oh, this is beautiful.
‐Oh, my God! Mine is huge!
‐Ooh, that's nice!
‐I know. This is gorgeous.
‐Look at that.
‐This is nice.
‐Wow!
♪♪
So, that's a dozen roses?
That's a dozen roses.
‐Wow. This is cool.
‐Thank you.
How do I mix‐and‐match items?
So, you come to our site, you
get three items in a small box,
six items in the medium box,
and then the large box,
you get a large bouquet of
flowers and two smaller gifts.
So, you select your box,
and then you mix and match
whatever you want.
How many different choices
do I have?
We've been actually at it
for only four months,
so the products
we have right now is ‐‐
Really?
You've only been doing this
for four months?
‐Four months, yes.
‐Candles, chocolates, truffles.
We have about 22 SKUs,
and, plus,
the two bouquets
that we have.
What about shipping?
This is heavy.
Before they attack you
on the numbers, I have to ‐‐
It's okay. We're ready.
We're totally ready.
No, before they atta‐‐
Before you get into the
touchy‐feely,
how much does it cost
to ship this?
'Cause it's heavy as hell.
Right now,
that box gets shipped
with our regional shipper
around $12 to $15.
‐That's the shipping costs?
‐That's the shipping costs.
‐Okay. This is quality stuff.
‐Quality.
What is an average cost of the
small box to make, with product?
The total cost with labor
and everything,
it's about $20
on our small box.
We sell that box for $50.
‐Okay.
Second box costs
about $34 to make, all in.
We sell it for $75.
Last box, it's $155.
‐To make it?
‐$68.
So, how did you guys
get into this business?
Yes, thank you.
Alex and I have known each
other for about 10 years.
We actually own a luxury
floral design company.
So, I've been in the flower
business for 25 years.
Okay.
I had my first
flower shop at 19.
I come very humble
backgrounds.
I had nothing coming to
this country as an immigrant,
so I've come up in flowers.
‐What country?
‐From where?
‐Iran.
So, I came here to study.
My parents just put me
in a plane, said,
"Here's 4 grand.
Go to America."
How old were you
when you came over?
15 1/2.
So you were 15 1/2,
came by yourself...
Yes, I worked at Burger King
at night after school.
Good for you.
Came here as an immigrant
myself, 9 years old.
My dad was selling pizzas
from a motor home,
sold ice cream in parks.
You name it.
I sold flowers
on a corner street.
I went to school,
Biochemistry major,
minor in Econ, wanted to be
a doctor, make dad proud.
I was volunteering
at the emergency room.
I'm premed,
I'm getting my degree.
Older gentleman came in,
all bloody and everything,
and I said, "You know what?
This is not for me.
I can't do that."
So we came out with Bouquet Bar
about two years ago,
and one day, we sat down
and we said,
"We're missing that right
technology person."
Sal's a good friend of mine,
known him for years.
So, my background is
digital media technology.
In my previous job, I co‐founded
a digital‐media company,
so for Bouquet Bar,
I'm in charge of all marketing
and all technology.
How much revenue
does your other business do?
About $3 million.
‐Whoa.
‐Annually.
‐Okay, kiddies.
‐Here we go.
And are we getting a piece of
that business in this deal, too?
We're not asking for that
business now.
Well, that's what you say.
[ Laughter ]
So, all of us, me included, have
many, many gifting companies.
I'm in the wedding business,
big‐time.
So let's just pick
any one of them.
Wicked Good Cupcakes.
The number‐one issue
of the business has been,
for the last four years
I've been involved,
is customer‐acquisition cost.
How's it gonna work?
So, the data is, our customer
acquisition's about $60.
We're utilizing
Google CPC ‐‐
So you're not making
any money at all.
As of right now ‐‐
We just launched.
I know, but revenues
in the last four months.
Let's get to the numbers
on sales.
Close to $100,000.
Close to $100,000
in four months?
How much of your own
money's in this business?
$600,000.
‐Whoa.
‐Wow!
And what about
any external money?
Or just your own money?
‐Just our own money.
What was the money spent on?
$300,000 of it was spent on
developing the product,
coming up with the process,
website, operation.
Okay.
Right now
I really want to stress,
we have a 6,200‐square‐foot
facility with a cooler.
We have about $300,000
worth of inventory
that will translate to about
$1 million to $1.2 million
in revenue.
We're ready to scale.
What about the focus on
the customer‐acquisition cost?
You've got to get it down
to between 10 and 15 bucks.
Aziz: Yeah, exactly.
That's what our goal is,
and that's gonna take
a little bit of time.
Well, who is your customer?
Great. Good question.
Our customer right now
is males and females
between 35 and 55,
60% female and 40% males.
What we are here to tell you is,
you know what?
We're gonna teach
people to gift.
People are scared to gift.
They don't know how to gift.
So, I have to ‐‐ I have to
call out the white elephant,
for me, in the room.
This looks just like
Sugarfina, right?
What is Sugarfina?
Sugarfina started off
with a box like this,
and they fill it
with different candies.
It's sort of their trademark.
It's not
their trademark, Lori.
Wait, wait, wait.
When people Google search,
they're gonna find Sugarfina,
and they're gonna find you.
And Sugarfina
is less expensive.
So, to me,
you need to do something
that is going to be
different.
And you are flower experts.
‐Yes.
But you've got to think
of how are you gonna beat it
or be more unique
or different.
And we're already working on
that, Lori, to answer that.
Yes, Sugarfina
does have candies.
We do have a lot of other stuff
into play right now
that I'm designing
for the next lines.
To me, if you had come in
with really cool, innovative,
different,
gorgeous floral things
and your price was great,
I'd be going to you.
Lori, there is, though ‐‐
I love your drive,
your passion, and who you are,
but you haven't figured
the business out yet,
and for that reason, I'm out.
‐Well, Lori ‐‐
♪♪
She's out, guys.
Okay. So, I'm gonna
jump in here.
I agree with Lori.
I'm very familiar
with Sugarfina, as well.
I see the point of difference
you're going for,
which is the mix of the candle
and the bath bomb.
I think that's gonna be easy
for someone else to replicate.
Your background ‐‐
it's incredible.
You guys should be very proud
of yourselves.
But the point of differentiation
is not big enough for me
to invest, so I'm out.
I think the people that don't
know they're gifting wrong,
don't know, because when I was
single 10 years ago,
my girlfriends, I would always
get them a crossbow,
a big fishing pole...
[ Laughter ]
And that's why
he lost them.
I lost the girlfriend, but I had
to learn that the hard way.
And I think the area
that you need help
is the area of educating people
that they don't know.
Yes.
I think that's
gonna be very hard.
And it's gonna cost
a lot of money, so...
I love this, but I'm out.
Let's talk about
some other markets ‐‐
the wedding market,
for example.
If you look at the wedding
market, billion‐dollar market ‐‐
$3 billion.
No one here is questioning
the quality of this box.
It's one of the best we've ever
seen on "Shark Tank," okay?
And it's one of those deals,
that's rare to me,
where I like a lot of it
but not enough of it,
because I want to pour
my $150,000
on the already‐solved
customer‐acquisition problem
and blow it up.
It's with heavy heart
that I say I'm out.
Okay. Now the riffraff's
out of the way.
Okay.
Okay. You've obviously looked
at corporate gift‐selling.
You guys have
bigger businesses
where you have salespeople,
or is it all walk‐in?
No, it's all salespeople.
So, can those salespeople
go out and sell
and just work on a commission
from their side?
Yeah.
How flexible are you to come up
with different designs?
'Cause it seems like
flowers are the hammer,
and everything else
is the nail.
We're innovative,
and I love to design more stuff.
All right.
So, getting down to business,
$150K for 10% is not enough.
Why'd you guys think 10%
was enough?
I think our ask is
not that high, Mark, honestly.
Million and a half valuation.
First, number one, you have to
put three or four companies
together in order to create
what we've created.
We know we're gonna need more
money, but we also ‐‐
What are you gonna need more
money for and when?
You know, basically,
in regards to, like,
sales and operations
and also staffing ‐‐
The whole point of being
a "virtual" e‐commerce company
is that you don't have to
have a big staff,
and you can outsource or you can
virtualize a lot of it,
but you can get help to do that.
So why would you need
to spend a lot more money?
I don't think ‐‐ I don't think
a lot more money,
but you know what?
For us, it's ‐‐
Or is it because you have all
your money in inventory?
No, like, for ex‐‐
No.
Guys, I was this close.
Mark, Mark, Mark.
H‐H‐‐ Here ‐‐ Here ‐‐
Mark, h‐here's the thing.
Look ‐‐
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Mark Cuban is the last chance
for a deal for Bouquet Bar,
an online gift‐box company.
Guys, I was this close.
Mark, Mark, Mark.
H‐H‐Here ‐‐
‐But that's just one number.
‐Mark, here's the thing.
You've got to give up more,
or you're not gonna get a deal.
No, it's just, you got to spend
so much more.
‐No, no, no.
‐We don't ‐‐
We have $100,000
in the bank right now.
If I have to refinance
my house,
if I have to put it
into this company,
I will do
whatever it takes.
No, I get that, right?
I get that.
But the thing is, right now ‐‐
Look, we have inventory.
We're re‐‐
We're ready to sell.
If you come in and say,
"Look, guys, I want you guys
to put this product in here,
and it's not gonna cost you
that much expense because
it's not that heavy.
Let's ship it,"
we can do that right now.
We're ready.
We got the salespeople to do it.
You have the people
to do it here.
All right, I'll make
you guys an offer.
$150,000 for 20%,
non‐negotiable.
Guys, I need an answer.
‐Mark...
‐Yes.
‐...we accept your offer.
‐We're here.
‐Done.
‐Nice.
All right.
‐Thanks.
‐All right.
Thank you, man.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Congratulations, you guys.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Bye.
Yeah!
‐Whoo!
‐[ Laughs ]
♪♪
‐Yeah!
‐Whoo!
Whoo!
Now we know what
your wife is getting.
Exactly right.
[ Laughter ]
It'll save me so much money
on flowers.
You have no idea.
‐Yeah!
‐That ‐‐ That was intense.
We got what we wanted.
So, I got to call my dad.
It means so much.
♪♪
It's not about ‐‐
It's about living
the dream.
People always say...
[ Sighs ]
...work hard.
And you know what?
I was in the Tank,
and they were dropping off.
They were dropping off.
And I always watch TV,
and when people do something,
and I was like, "You know what?
Say this, say that, say that."
And I was in the Tank,
and I said, "Don't give up.
Don't give up. Whatever you say,
don't give up."
Now the hard work
begins.
♪♪
Narrator: In season 4,
Jeffrey Simon and Marc Newburger
made a deal with Lori Greiner
for their patented car‐seat
gap‐filler, the Drop Stop.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
Newburger: Today, we're in
our hometown of Los Angeles,
meeting with the third‐largest
police department
in the United States.
The department's been
testing Drop Stops
for the last three months,
and it's been a huge success.
Welcome to police headquarters.
Happy to be here.
Greiner:
I really respect policemen.
They risk their lives every day
to help protect us,
so we couldn't be more thrilled
to be helping
our everyday heroes.
What we want to do
is really decrease the number
of traffic collisions for all
officers and the public.
After three months, we've had
zero traffic‐related accidents.
So we will be outfitting
3,000 of our police cars...
‐Wow.
‐...with Drop Stops.
Simon: People used to think
it was a joke
when we said Drop Stop
could actually reduce
driver distraction.
Now, to have this
police department
equip their vehicles
with Drop Stop,
it's a huge validation for why
we set out to do what we did.
We have a surprise
to present to y'all.
The very first glow‐in‐the‐dark
Drop Stops.
Simon: The time has come
for Drop Stop
to become standard equipment
in every single vehicle.
You have seat belts,
you have an airbag.
Now it's time
to have a Drop Stop.
Newburger: We had
$1.3 million in sales
in our first three years
of business.
Five years since
doing a deal with Lori,
we've hit $28 million.
Thank you guys so much.
We're L. A. boys.
This is our hometown,
so to know that we can make
a difference
in this city that we love
is an incredible feeling.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a discreet way to stay safer.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Pat Hughes.
And I'm Mike Fox.
Our product is the Wingman,
and we're here today
seeking $200,000
in exchange for 12 1/2%
of our business.
We're friends
and business partners
from Milwaukee, Wisconsin,
and we spend a lot of time
on the water.
But there was always one thing
getting in our way.
Life jackets!
So we didn't wear them.
Why? Because foam life jackets
are bulky and inherently buoyant
while inflatable life jackets
are loose‐fitting,
awkward, and not designed
for in‐water activities.
Which is why
we created...
Both: The Wingman.
The Wingman is one of
the world's thinnest
and most versatile
life jackets
and the first designed
for in‐water activitis
like swimming
and surfing.
So let's show you
how it works.
If you find yourself
in an emergency,
you simply pull down
on the ripcord...
[ Laughter ]
...the Wingman instantly floats
you face‐up from any position,
and it can be used over and over
again with a new CO2.
By partnering
with the right Shark,
we can make the Wingman
the leader in water safety.
Saving one life would
make this product worthwhile,
but we know that we're gonna do
a lot better than that.
So, who wants to blow this
market out of the water?
[ Laughing ]
‐Huh.
‐All right.
‐Wow!
‐Can we try them on?
Oh, absolutely.
We got some samples for
you guys to touch, try out.
Yeah, they're loaded,
so feel free to blast it off.
Lori.
Mr. Wonderful.
Very cool.
Thank you.
And so, they are armed.
You just put them on,
fasten the straps
underneath your arm,
pull down on the ripcord
like your life depends on it.
Once you actually
trigger the Wingman,
is there a cartridge replacement
to make it inflatable again?
Yes, you can use it over
and over again
with a new CO2 cylinder.
[ Laughter ]
‐Sorry.
‐You have to buckle it.
Yeah. So you want to
buckle it underneath.
There you go.
‐All right.
How do I get it
off now?
It doesn't come off 'cause
you didn't buckle it.
‐Yeah.
‐Oh, my God. I'm gonna ‐‐
Oh, I can't get it off,
for real.
You look great in it.
You look great.
‐Can you help me?
‐You're not gonna drown,
but you're gonna strangle in it.
‐Ah.
[ Loud pop ]
Aah!
‐Whoa!
‐Oh, my God!
Boom goes the dynamite!
[ Laughter ]
So, you want to fasten
the straps before you...
Oh, my God.
‐Wow.
‐Are you okay?
Sara, are you okay?
Yeah, yeah.
So, you need
to fasten it
because the resistance
allows the zipper to open.
‐Okay.
‐Oh, my God.
That was just
a horrifying experience.
[ Laughter ]
So, doesn't this require
some sort
of organizational approvement
from somebody ‐‐
Yes. So, this is approved
by the U. S. Coast Guard,
and that was
a huge hurdle for us.
‐Oh, wow.
‐But inflatable life jackets
are not approved
for activities
where there's a likelihood
of hitting your head.
So, for instance, water‐skiing,
white‐water kayaking,
where there's a higher potential
of you being incapacitated.
Is there a model
that you could offer
that auto‐inflates
when it hits water?
Okay. So, this has actually
always been the long‐term vision
for this product was
to make it a smart device.
Maybe I can tell you
a little bit more
about where this idea
came from,
since it's...
‐Yeah, please.
When I was in college
a few years ago,
I participated
in my first triathlon.
And, sadly, during the race,
another participant drowned,
and I was saddened by how
preventable that tragedy seemed.
I thought, "There must be
some type of piece
of safety equipment that you
could wear in a race like this
where, if your mouth
is submerged for 30 seconds,
it knows that
and it deploys.
So that, to us, is the end‐all,
be‐all of water safety.
Right, right.
But you're a ways off from that.
Both: Yes.
But you believe
it's achievable?
Absolutely.
The first step was getting
a Coast Guard‐approved vest
in the ideal configuration,
and so, for us,
this is it.
Okay. I think we get it.
Let's talk about revenue.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐How much have you made so far?
Well, how much do they sell them
for, and what's your cost?
The retail price is $249.
Our landed cost is $65.
And in the past
10 months,
we've shipped
$120,000 worth of product.
So our bread‐and‐butter
customers so far are kayakers,
stand‐up paddleboarders,
surfers, and fishermen.
O'Leary:
But the purchase of them
is always at the point of sale
at the marina.
I'm assuming you don't have any
retail distribution yet, right?
Not yet, but we see
that as a big part
of our sales model.
But how low can you get
the price point down?
Because the $249, you've got to
really be dedicated
to being a water enthusiast
or an outdoor...
Yeah. So, we've been ordering
in such small quantities
up to this point ‐‐
less than a thousand ‐‐
we think once we start
hitting better quantities
that we can bring
the price down.
So, it's lighter, it's thinner,
it's easier to store.
Mm‐hmm.
It seems very,
very, very smart to me,
if I had to put one on,
I would want to be wearing that
over anything
I've ever seen.
‐Mm‐hmm.
I feel it's a little too early
for me to be investing
because I want you to be there
where you hit everything
you need to hit to then
become the "it" life vest.
But at the moment,
it's not there, so I'm out.
Okay. Thank you
for your feedback.
So, I hesitate in getting
involved in anything
that is liability‐focused,
where someone might actually
not come out alive
because of the use
of the product,
so for that reason, I'm out.
Thank you
for your feedback.
I think it's super‐cool,
but it is really a niche market
in a very crowded space,
so I'm out.
Okay.
Guys, this is just such a tough,
incredibly competitive market.
You got to spend a lot of money
in order to get to the point
where you make a lot of money,
and that's the catch‐22
you guys are probably
running into right now.
It's just not a fit for me,
guys, so I'm out.
♪♪
Okay, boys, four Sharks out.
I'm your last hope.
I like the product,
but it's so embryonic.
Um...
I'll give you the $200K...
but I want half.
50%.
Thank you
for the offer.
You're not gonna call him
Mr. Wonderful any more, are you?
Excuse me. I think it's
the only offer you have.
Um...
That's certainly more equity
than we came in here
looking to give up.
We think the upside
on this product is huge, so ‐‐
Is there anything protectable
about it
that would make it seem
more valuable to him.
We have a U. S. patent granted
on this product, so...
‐You have a utility patent?
‐Utility patent granted.
‐And it's published?
‐And it covers what?
So, the unique things that
allowed us to make it sleeker.
So, for instance,
one of the big things
was moving that CO2 cylinder
to the back.
Also, in order to get this
lay‐flat configuration,
we needed a new type
of zipper,
so we created this
triple‐bursting zipper
that opens at both ends,
opens in the back,
so that's a big part
of our patent.
O'Leary:
And those attributes have merit,
but they don't change
the distribution problem.
The challenge is getting
this business
to do $2 million or $3 million
or $4 million in sales.
So, we've never been on cycle,
from a retail perspective.
We're about to go
to three
of the biggest
industry trade shows, so ‐‐
I care about right now.
I know what the risk is.
I know what the opportunity is.
And we value what you would
bring to this business,
so would you do
$200,000 for...
...20%?
No.
It's not interesting.
You know, I'm very impressed
that you got the Coast Guard
to endorse it.
That, I've learned,
matters a lot.
But you guys are so far
from distribution.
You know, most people
that come in the Shark Tank
don't get any offer at all.
You have one,
and it's your last hope
because I didn't hear anybody
else making you an offer.
Would you do
$200,000 for...
...25%?
Not enough.
Mr. Wonderful, we're gonna have
to decline that 50/50 offer.
‐Good for you guys.
‐Good for you.
‐Yeah.
‐Well, good luck.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Congrats on the business, guys.
‐Good luck at the trade show.
‐Congratulations on everything.
Even though we didn't get
a deal today,
we're gonna keep going
with our product.
This is all about
saving lives,
and we know that if we get
the product out there,
we can help to make
a difference.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is way to connect
African designers
with a global marketplace.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Kelechi Anyadiegwa.
I'm from Atlanta, Georgia,
and I'm the founder and C. E. O.
of Zuvaa.
Today, I'm looking for $460,000
in exchange for 10%
of my company.
Growing up Nigerian,
I was always enamored
by unique prints and textiles.
The colors, the vibrancy ‐‐
it always amazed me.
And I knew there were
talented designers
on the African continent
who had a gift for creating
beautiful pieces.
But the problem is, these
designers did not have the tools
nor the resources
to tap a global market.
This is why I created Zuvaa.
We are the fastest‐growing
online marketplace
for global design.
We connect these incredibly
talented designers
with consumers globally who are
looking for unique finds.
Let me tell you how it works.
Consumers simply browse
our online marketplace
currently consisting over 85
handpicked, curated designers.
Once they've placed
their orders,
their items are shipped to them
directly from the designer
or from our fulfillment center
in Atlanta, Georgia.
Madison is wearing Titi's
Closet, and she is from Nigeria,
so it's a beautiful jumpsuit
with peplum on the sides
and on the top.
And then Michelle is wearing
a designer from Zambia.
And so she likes to mix
her prints
using wax prints and chiffons
in her materials.
And then, this designer's
also from Nigeria,
and this is
an all‐chiffon material,
and so it's really beachy.
Now join me as we show the world
the beauty of Africa
through design.
I'd love to show you guys
some samples.
‐Sure.
‐Just to give you an idea of ‐‐
‐Please do!
‐Oh, that's nice.
So, yeah, you can just kind of
pass them down.
I wanted you guys to see more
of the quality of the pieces.
Daymond, what you're holding
actually comes from Nigeria,
and it's made out of ashoké,
which is woven textile,
and that one comes from Benin,
and it's made with Ankara print,
wax print, and suede.
Could I wear this
at the pool?
That looks fabulous on you,
Mr. Wonderful.
I do wear wraps, you know.
I love that.
So, Kele, how do you
find these women?
So, we actually find it
by word of mouth.
And we also have a very strict
vetting policy,
so all designers
who are interested
in selling through Zuvaa,
they send us their samples.
And we're able to really check
quality control
as well as understanding
what their process is
for fulfillment
and customer service.
How did you come up
with his idea?
I'm a first‐generation Nigerian.
This is my culture, right?
I grew up wearing these pieces.
I actually started Zuvaa
while I was in grad school.
I was at Carnegie‐Mellon,
and during that time,
I start to freelance
in social‐media marketing,
and people would ask me
all the time,
"Kelechi, where'd you get that?"
I realized how inaccessible
African prints and textiles
were to people
in Western markets.
‐Right.
‐So I started with
about a $500 investment,
and I was able to turn that
into over $2 million...
Whoa!
...in sales
in under 2 1/2 years.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
‐Wow!
‐That's amazing.
‐Thank you.
‐Okay.
So, explain, if I'm a designer
and I want to be on your site,
what is the financial
relationship?
So, we charge
a 17% flat commission
to be on the marketplace,
and then we also charge
a monthly fee of $50.
And how many visitors
do you have to the site?
Monthly, we have
about 120,000 visitors.
‐Good for you.
‐So, now the question.
That's fabulous.
Last month, what
did you do in revenue?
Monthly, we're doing about
$220,000 in sales,
so about $50,000 in revenue.
So you make $50K a month.
Mm‐hmm.
That's basically
off of your commission.
‐Yes.
‐Right.
So, basically,
you have no risk.
‐Yeah.
‐Which is brilliant.
‐But let me ask something.
There is a risk. You know,
when women order online,
it's a higher return rate often
because they order
two sizes, right?
"I don't know if I'm a 7
or an 8 today," right?
Yeah, that's happened.
What happens in the event
of a return?
Because you either have to put
that back in inventory
or send it back to Africa.
What happens in that?
Yeah. So, Zuvaa handles all
the returns for the customers.
So they get a return slip, and,
you know, they send the items
back to us in Atlanta,
and then we send those items
back to the designers
usually every quarter or so
to cut down on costs.
‐You're getting $50K a month.
What does it cost you to run it?
You got some staff?
Yes. I mean, our burn,
monthly, is about $50K,
so we break even monthly.
Okay. So what's the vision for
why it's worth $4.6 million?
So, our valuation is really
just based
off of 2X multiple
of our GMV from last year.
Has anybody paid that value?
Is anybody invested in it?
No, we haven't had
any investment.
We've been bootstrapped
the whole three years.
‐So you own 100% of it?
‐I own 92%.
And who owns the other 8%?
My other advisers.
So I'm gonna guess right now
you're very flexible
on valuation.
Well, she's saying
that she's worth $4.6 million
right now, correct?
‐Yes.
Greiner:
You're doing fantastic.
Mm‐hmm.
So why do you need a Shark?
There's so much more that I want
to do with this company, right?
I want for us to be able
to really create global impact
and for people around the world
to see the beauty
of African fashion design
beyond just fashion, right?
I mean, there's home apparel,
there's art.
There's so much beauty
that's coming out of Africa,
so for us to really scale up,
we're going to need investment
to build out
a scalable online platform.
Right now, our online platform
does not meet the needs
of our vendors or our consumers.
What is the price‐point range
for your outfits?
So, we range from $50 to $250.
That's not bad.
That's reasonably priced
for what this is.
‐Yeah.
‐It looks good.
You know, I think the mistake
in your deal,
just right out of the gate here,
$460,000 is a lot of money.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐But she's got to scale.
Yeah, but I'm having a hard time
at $4.6 million.
How many designers
do you want to grow to?
On the continent right now,
there are hundreds,
if not thousands of designers
who could do a variety of
pieces, right?
And that's what I'm really
looking to scale up to.
Look, I think what you've
accomplished is amazing.
Thank you.
But I can't get to where
you are with the valuation.
$460,000 is a big swallow
for 10%, and so I'm out.
Okay, thank you, Mark.
Kelechi,
I'm really proud of you.
‐Thank you.
‐I'm proud of what you've done.
You're an Atlanta girl.
You know, started Spanx
from Atlanta,
so it's a good place to start
something, for sure.
Um...
I'm ‐‐ I'm also struggling
with your valuation.
‐Okay.
‐You don't say.
It's really high.
We're growing incredibly fast,
and if we do get the investment
from one of you Sharks,
we'll be able to use that
to grow even faster.
I feel like,
from what you've been able to do
so far on your own,
I'd count on you to keep going
without having to give up
a big chunk of equity
that I would need to ‐‐
What chunk of equity
do you think that would be?
[ Inhales sharply ]
Like 50%.
‐Cuban: Ha!
‐O'Leary: Ouch.
Yippee‐yi‐yo ki‐yay.
Okay. Yeah, I couldn't give up
50% of my company ‐‐
definitely
not at such an early stage.
And I don't think
you should.
The more that you maintain
ownership,
the more you're gonna
be able to direct it
the way that you want to.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Okay, then.
You are making
a tremendous difference
in African women's lives.
I think you're doing
amazing all on your own.
I don't want to take
a chunk of your company,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
John: All right.
So here's my thoughts on it.
So, I had the honor of going
to Kenya
with President Obama
two years ago,
and believe it or not,
"Shark Tank" is big there.
You're like a lightning bolt
for entrepreneurship
because, in that continent,
literally,
women have carried the economy
on their heads and their backs.
Absolutely.
My biggest challenge is,
I'm a target.
A target?
In California,
there's a certain law
that anybody can walk up
to a product
that is being sold
in a public market,
and they can create
a class‐action lawsuit.
Mm‐hmm.
And dealing with 80 or 100
or 300 designers,
there's a lot
in that vetting process,
and I become almost a liability
for you.
A liability because there might
be an issue with the pieces?
‐Because anybody can sue you.
‐Yeah.
He's saying, because if
there's big pockets with you,
there might be a target.
‐Absolutely.
I definitely want to be here
with you, but I'll be a target.
Okay.
I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
‐Well, then...
‐[ Laughs ]
The equity valuation
doesn't work,
and you heard it
from four Sharks.
Beautifully said...
‐I didn't say that.
...wonderfully spoken,
all of that crap ‐‐
at the end, they didn't
give you any money.
You know, I like
to deal in reality.
I hope you do, too, okay?
‐Mm‐hmm.
I don't think your company's
worth $460,000 right now.
The only way it works is
I loan it to you, all right?
‐Okay.
‐I give you debt.
I'll do it at 12%, all right?
I want 10% of the company
for providing that capital,
because you've at least proven
you have a business.
I'm impressed.
But the cold, hard reality is,
you asked for too much.
♪♪
That's my offer.
Yes or no?
Uh, thank you so much, Kevin,
but I have to decline that.
‐Good for you.
‐That's right.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate the offer.
But thank you, guys.
‐Uh‐huh, good luck.
I was really confident about
the amount that I asked for,
so even though Kevin
wasn't really feeling it,
I believe in my heart
that's what we're worth.
Narrator:
Next up is a product
designed to keep germs
out of a baby's mouth.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Nicki Radzely,
founder of Doddle & Co., the
creator of the Pop pacifier.
I'm here today seeking
a $250,000 investment
for 5% of my company.
Everybody has seen a pacifier or
used a pacifier before, right?
Kevin, yeah?
[ Laughter ]
Babies use pacifiers
to soothe themselves
and it allows parents to come up
for a breath of air.
The only problem with pacifiers
is, for 82 years,
they've been falling, right?
They fall everywhere
and all the time.
Like in my life,
I'm trying to diaper my baby
in a public restroom, and what
happens time and time again?
A pacifier falls on the floor,
and I have to do one
of two things ‐‐ run to a sink,
apply the 5‐second rule, or...
There's always
a 5‐second rule.
...what most parents do...
Ugh! Yuck!
‐Greiner: Gross.
‐[ Laughs ]
Gone are the days.
Introducing the Pop pacifier.
♪♪
We've built a pacifier
with a patented silicone
protective bubble
around the nipple,
so now every single time
you give your baby a Pop,
you simply pop it like this,
the baby takes over from there,
and every single
time they drop their pacifier,
what happens?
The nipple pops back
into a bubble,
keeping it clean
every single time.
Let's take a look at our babies.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
So, Sharks, who would like
to pop open their wallets
and help me soothe babies
and their parents?
[ Laughter ]
‐All right.
‐Can we see samples?
‐Yes, yes.
You can pick a color, any color.
I love your shoes.
‐Oh, thank you.
‐Like, insanely love them.
‐Thank you.
‐What color you want, Lori?
Pink.
The pink is Make Me Blush, and
that color is Corally Yours.
That is In Teal Life.
Okay. I'm all about
the neon.
Ah.
So, am I doing it right in that
you just push it like that?
That's it?
‐Yes.
Then the baby sucks it.
You don't try to push it
all the way through.
Right. You don't have to do
a lock or stick it in place.
And notice how gentle it is.
It's zero to six months
for those newborn babies.
There you go.
There it is.
He's sucking on it.
Oh, keep it in there.
This is ‐‐
Okay. So, first if all...
Wah! Wah!
...this is cool.
‐Ah, thank you.
‐I'm a mom.
I have four children
under the age of 7.
I have an 18‐month‐old at home,
so I have been living
in the world of pacifiers.
Right?
And they're always on the floor.
So this, you're saying,
is for zero to six months?
Yes. Starting out,
this is our launch product.
We just launched
four months ago.
‐Oh, you did?
‐Yes.
Oh, you're a new
entrepreneur.
‐I'm a baby.
‐You're a baby!
‐Welcome!
Thank you.
Yes, zero to six months,
and then we will eventually be
releasing a 6 to 12 months.
Wait.
Let me ask you something.
Does it pop out more often from
the baby's mouth because, um...
‐It's trying to retract?
‐Good question.
Yeah, if the baby moves it
a little bit, it just pops out?
So are you creating
more of a challenge?
No, we're not, and it kind of
mimics breastfeeding,
to a certain extent,
but we have seen in the about
25,000‐plus units,
our Pops that we've been able to
sell in the last four months,
that parents love it.
I notice all the engineering
design of it
is, if it's like this,
they have to be sucking,
but the minute they stop
sucking, does it pop out?
Sometimes, if they
are sucking on it
and they're falling asleep,
it depends on, like,
where they end their motion.
They keep it in their mouth.
So, the 25,000 units you sold,
were they part of a Kickstarter,
or was that real sales
to retail?
So, in 2015, we were fully
funded on Kickstarter.
In 2016, we prototyped it,
countless iterations.
And then, four months ago,
we fulfilled 25,000 units.
Any of the baby retailers
pick it up yet?
Yeah, so we are in Nordstrom
and Buy Buy Baby.
Do you have a patent?
So, we have a fully issued
utility patent.
How much do each one of these
units cost to make?
So, I land for about $1.20.
I wholesale at $5,
and I retail at $9.99.
And what does that amount to
in sales?
$117,000 for 2017, but ‐‐
Okay, Nicki, let's address
this elephant in the room.
You know your valuation
is crazy.
[ Laughing ]
I hope not.
Why is it worth $5 million
right now?
$5 million, yes.
Okay.
Last year, I did a small
Friends and Family Round.
To Friends and Family
convertible note,
I did $433,000.
‐There you go. Okay.
‐What value was that at?
2.5.
We had yet to pass safety.
We had yet to engineer it
correctly
so that it would pop every
single time it came out.
Okay, so you found some suckers
for 2.5 to invest.
‐No!
‐Come on, now.
And then we had all this way
to de‐risk it, right?
We had to go into production,
we had to get distribution
and warehousing and logistics,
and all that stuff worked out.
Now that, with our pipeline
that we're building,
then the interest
from retailers,
launching in other countries...
How do you know this is gonna be
a hit right now?
It's all lined up.
‐I'm out.
‐It is a hit.
I'm sorry.
We take affordable steps.
‐I am out.
‐Okay.
No, Nicki, it is a hit, and
it's, as a mom, it's a hit.
As a dad, it's a hit, too.
Okay.
As a future teller,
it sucks.
Come on!
I'd like to make you an offer,
and I'll go in
at the friendly and family round
value of $2.5 million.
So I'll do
the $250,000 at 10%.
Okay.
I don't agree that you've
doubled the value yet.
‐So, what do you need from us?
‐Money's not an issue, really.
Money doesn't seem
like it's your issue,
so I'm trying to get
to the heart of, like,
what can I offer you?
You're already in Nordstrom,
which is amazing.
I'm looking for that expertise
of, like, what's around
the corner
and how to build
a strong team.
What I hear you saying
is you want ‐‐
you need an adviser
more than anything, okay?
So I've walked this road, I've
dealt in mostly female products.
Yes, which we are.
Most of the people that
work for me are mothers.
I'm a mother.
I'm gonna offer you
$250,000 for 15%.
Okay.
And the reason why I believe
it's 15% ‐‐
I know he offered you 10% ‐‐
but I have a website
that millions of women are
going to currently.
I can highlight you.
Okay.
She just grew a fin.
She's a Shark.
[ Laughter ]
‐But I need a response.
‐Yes!
So tell me ‐‐
are we gonna ‐‐
Would anyone else like
to make an offer
so that I don't leave
anyone out?
Are you saying
she's not good enough?
I'm up against Mr. Wonderful.
I can't loses to Mr. Wonderful.
Nicki, are you actually
thinking about this?
‐Huh? Yes.
‐So, Nicki, what is ‐‐
what is your reservation?
Why are you holding?
I just want to make sure that
I don't leave anyone out.
♪♪
I love what you're doing.
I have total respect
for what you're doing.
I just think she'd be
a better partner for you,
and I think you're crazy ‐‐
Not so fast, Mark.
She's very expensive.
I think you're crazy
to even think twice
'cause I'm sitting next to her,
and I'm about to tell her
to give you a 24‐second
clock, because ‐‐
Okay, okay.
Once somebody else drops out,
that's going up.
No, no, okay.
Nicki, her value becomes more
when other Sharks drop out,
so you need to really think
about this right now.
The more you hesitate, you don't
know what's gonna happen.
Narrator: One Shark is out,
and Nicki has two offers
on the table
for her innovative pacifier,
the Pop.
Nicki, you need to really think
about this right now.
The more you hesitate, you don't
know what's gonna happen.
Okay.
Nicki, the thing
I'm thinking is...
‐Okay.
‐I love better mousetraps.
I love things that are clever.
I think that Sara gave you
a really good offer.
I love your platform.
And I'm about to tell Sara
that if all these
other offers are gone,
she should up it to 20%.
I know, I know.
So I'm out,
but I'm telling you ‐‐
‐Okay.
‐If I were to say,
"I'd like to partner with Sara,"
we'd need more stake in the game
is the problem.
You know, because we both
have to wake up
and really work for you.
These two Shark women are gonna
take a huge bite out of you
that Mr. Wonderful doesn't
think is a good deal.
I realize that.
‐Sara.
‐Yes?
Would you like to partner
on this?
What do you have in mind?
Um, you were at 15%.
I think we'd need to be
at 20%...
‐Ouch! Ouch!
‐...so that we'd each be 10%.
‐Oh.
‐God...
It's so expensive.
I would handle for you
the retail end
and helping to blow it up
and really get this out
as a household name.
So I will do the deal
with Lori.
Okay.
Is that the only way
you'll do the deal?
Yes.
So now you have
two distinct offers.
‐Yes.
‐What are you going to do?
‐I would like to counter both.
‐Ooh.
I would like to throw it
out there to see if you could
come in with more cash
for the 20%.
Maybe half a million dollars.
‐Wow.
And I would like to see
if Mr. Wonderful ‐‐
if you would come down to 7%...
‐Mm.
‐...for $250,000.
I don't want to fall below
my last round.
Well, I'm giving you exactly
what your last round was.
I will stay at 10%
because I actually think
I add a lot of value, as well.
More than half of my companies
are run by women just like you,
and they make me
a lot of money.
So at the end of the day,
I'd be happy to invest in you,
but I'm not gonna do it
for less than 10%
because I want to care
about my investment.
So I want skin
in the game, too.
Blakely: Everybody wants skin
in the game.
Yes.
But you have, I think,
a really beautiful opportunity
standing there
with Sara and I.
Our offer holds at 20%...
‐It does.
‐Mine's at 10%.
‐...but you get two Sharks.
What are you gonna do?
‐What am I gonna do?
You've got to make a decision.
This is your moment.
Then, I believe that I...
♪♪
...am gonna make a deal
with you.
‐Oh!
‐Thank you very much.
I am just thrilled
to be working with you.
Bad move. Bad move.
‐Me too.
‐That's great.
Thank you.
Bad valuation,
bad judge of character.
Blakely: No way, Jose.
And that is how
you do a deal.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Congratulations.
Radzely: I believe I made a deal
with the best Shark
that put the best offer forward,
so I'm thrilled to be working
with Mr. Wonderful.
Greiner:
Are you in shock?
I can't believe
I lost a deal to you.
I know. Shocking.
You know, Sara,
you're so greedy.
You're so greedy.
♪♪